The voter intimidation is starting, my friends.
Today's example is actually an in uniform
police officer doing it.
This took place in Miami, Florida.
A police officer in uniform with a Trump mask
that says Trump no more B.S. walking around
a polling place.
The officer is Daniel, you Beda wearing a
Trump 20-20 mask inside a polling place at
Miami's government center.
Attorney Steve Simon, who is also chairman
of the Miami Dade Democratic Party, says,
quote, He may have been going to vote, but
he was in full uniform with the mask and a
gun.
That's voter intimidation.
And indeed, it is illegal in the state of
Florida.
Florida's 20-20 statutes one oh for DOT 32,
referring to political activities of state,
county and municipal officers and employees,
says that no officer of the state or any county
or municipality can use their authority to
influence an election or to influence a vote,
period.
And importantly, that, quote, no employees
of the state can participate in any political
campaign while on duty if you violate it.
It's actually a misdemeanor in the first degree.
Miami police immediately alerted to it by
people who saw this.
They tweeted about it saying, quote, We are
aware of the photograph being circulated of
a Miami police officer wearing a political
mask in uniform.
This behavior is unacceptable, a violation
of department policy and is being addressed
immediately.
Now, of course, there is a bigger issue.
This is an officer who broke the law.
He shouldn't be working in law enforcement,
period.
But we have no national database of bad actor
police officers.
We have no such requirement.
We likely won't anytime soon.
As I mentioned months ago, when the George
Floyd protest started in the context of the
police reforms.
I would like to see a national bad actors
database, something that would be brutally
fought to the death by police unions.
And more than likely, we will get a sort of
meaningless slap on the wrist coming for this
officer.
Don't worry, he won't do it again, at least
not for four more years.
Big consequences.
And in all seriousness, someone sworn to uphold
the law, breaking the law while in uniform.
A police department is as good as its worst
officer.
And this is an individual, Daniel, you Beta,
who may end up with a couple of weeks of paid
administrative leave while they investigate
what happened.
Does anybody think that's going to teach this
guy a lesson?
But as I've said before, keep me posted on
this stuff.
If you come across it.
I got an email yesterday.
I don't want to say too much because I want
to look at it myself.
But I got an email yesterday not about intimidation.
Well, actually, it sort of is.
It's intimidation by text message.
OK.
I'm asking for more information and I'm going
back and forth with the viewer to really vet
the story.
But I may have that for you tomorrow or the
next day.
But if you see intimidation, if you get intimidatory
emails, if you see intimidation at polling
places, let me know.
Video is, of course, ideal.
If you can safely and legally recorded.
If you can't let me know what happened.
But the reports are starting to come in.
And I can only imagine because listen, they've
said right.
Trump said go and monitor polling places.
They've said we're going to try to have law
enforcement of possibly federal military at
polling places.
They've mentioned everything in passing at
some point and who knows what they're actually
going to try to do.
So help.
Help me get the word out, if indeed
you are
seeing that.